we do have an announcement to make which
is that indeed Hillary Clinton has one
in Virginia uh I mean I I guess I wish I
could say that this is just so great but
it's shocking to me that we didn't know
that until 1040 p.m. eastern time
because really that should have gone
pretty early we do have another
projection to make however and that is
something that um uh may continue to
push us in the direction of Donald Trump
being president of the United States as
shocking as that might be or it might be
something that helps Hillary Clinton um
okay or we might have no projection
whatsoever Michigan is still in the
direction of Donald Trump that's scary
that's horrifying that's disturbing
Wisconsin Donald Trump is ahead with now
nearly fifty percent of the vote in
which is very very very disturbing um
and I'm gonna break my drinking no
drinking policy Mary it's been months
right yeah it's been it's been least six
months is I had a drink I think I'm
gonna pop a bottle or something tonight
yeah um who who could have imagined this
I know it's crazy that not Trump
supporter who's been sending me a
hundred emails a day for the last six
months I guess they don't worry about
politics than I do you know what it is
is like we completely underestimated the
level to which people hate Hillary
Clinton yeah that's it that's it
actually I don't say we I want to say
the regular media not in the mainstream
media but just people who parrot the the
left-leaning democratic-leaning talking
points I this is a statement no matter
if Hillary Clinton wins tonight this is
a clear definitive statement that
America does not want Hillary Clinton
because it should not be this close yes
she wins this is by the skin of her
teeth and that's not a mandate even
though they're gonna try to spin it to
be one uh there's somebody in our chat
who is saying um just embrace nihilism
and laugh don't even give an F which is
interesting it's I that's not a bad
approach right i mean i know where i am
be honest with you yes like whatever
dude it's the the sun's gonna come up
tomorrow no matter what Dow futures now
down six hundred point lead out looking
like maybe the worst day for the stock
market in a very very very long time um
I think that tomorrow is not going to be
a good day to look at my vanguard
account think that that uh that's a
that's a agree we can definitely say uh
ok I think very soon we're going to get
something out of Pennsylvania and I
think it's going to be for Hillary
Clinton more than likely yeah uh we'll
take a look at that pretty soon in the
meantime let's hear from 504 area code
we've got a call from 504 is this the
same call anything I don't know let's
see ya hi what's your name my name is
Teena Marie Tina Marie we just spoke
with you Tina how are you i'm mad i'm a
mere it's dave is gonna be me on the air
hi it's the same Tina thanks for the
call Tina we really appreciate you
calling in yeah yeah thank you so much
appreciate we will make sure we give
everyone a chain letter to 62 and we
will uh let's let's block her maybe I
think we'll have to get on that 262
you're on with us a name in town see
that there is party calling from
Fayetteville Arkansas I'm sorry I'm
having a real hard time hearing you can
we turn up the caller's a little bit
guys and then maybe you can tell me
again your name and where you're calling
from this is freddy multimodel from
Arkansas ok Arkansas perfect what's
going on well I've been trying to get
through for a while that's fine we'll
have you in the line just want to say I
love everything you do of the show thank
you and also I want to say that I'm
freaking terrified by your map right now
yeah because it's not looking good for
who for Hillary Clinton and yes I'll get
me wrong i am not far at all but i would
prefer her to Donald Trump yeah no I
know you mean it's pretty scary right
now so y'all did you vote for her I want
to ask what you think about all these
off transporters what's going to happen
with all that energy that he's ladies
all this commotion what do you think is
going to happen to have to be election
even if Hillary when well I i think it's
going to be chaos for a while i think is
going to be incredibly chaotic I
think depending on who wins and what the
reaction is we might have not
insignificant levels of violence
although I hope that that doesn't happen
and I think that we're really in for
were really in for something from now
until the inauguration of President
Trump and it is going to be I mean such
a disaster because we've got a guy here
who has no idea about anything all those
plans are i'll put the right people in
and we're going to be great and it's
going to be terrific in this entire
thing there's nothing there and were
what what is Trump going to do for the
next three months until inauguration I
guess try to figure out how to be
President or something I don't know I
think he's going to try to get attention
as usual yeah but with that said I also
wanted to say that you and Patrick are
absolutely adorable will feel anything
all right what about Rachel yeah I'm
insulted I think he probably can't hear
you because of how we're taking the
calls right now okay can you hear Rachel
by the way a little bit yeah I didn't
accept you understand what she said
though oh I said I'm insulted because
you didn't include me in that oh well
you're adorable to but sorry I'm not
into that kind of thing oh I get it ok
so you dislike Hillary Clinton but did
you vote for her I'm sorry what did you
fit did you vote for Hillary Clinton
even though you dislike her of course
you didn't eat myself for it but I did
what do you dislike about her what do
you dislike about her I'll translate
seems like you just can't hear Rachel
what do you dislike about Hillary
Clinton okay not very good uh no that
and it was a great call but it came to a
stop ultimately and then it did not go
any further uh okay so let's reset where
we are currently Trump 167 and we can go
to the map Rachel Trump 167 Clinton 122
we are awaiting some results that are
going to really uh indicate to us what
it is that is going to happen tonight
and I think we can put the map up guys
here we've got it yep this is disturbing
this is a very very disturbing situation
and uh Ben Dixon is back he may be
drinking alcohol
are you drinking it's just a little red
wine okay so Ben is gonna be back uh we
may be ready to sort of wrap this thing
up kinda soon i think that soon we're
gonna know yeah just in the in the
opposite or you mean by that I think
soon it's going to become clear that
Hillary Clinton is not going to be the
next president of the United States
don't say what they just called the call
Michigan now nothing happened yet uh but
they're just talking about you know
different scenarios etcetera uh that's
that's sort of what's going on right now
um will take a couple more calls and I
think we're gonna get to I I hate to say
guys I think we're getting to the end
ironic thing coming please um okay and
Rachel make sure to switch to yourself
when you're talkin see what's going on
let's take the 336 area code 336 name
and town where you calling from I'm on
Cano form useful jalama cool what's
going on I wonder if anything good
company can't win anything at all oh
thank you going to win but you can get
come out of it you i'm sorry you're
saying I'm just have enough I don't know
if it's just me can you hear the collars
okay I've got to turn the colors up I
think you what was the exact question
again um if they did come out of
traveling I'll know if you're choking
one get there makes you more epithet 'ok
or what energized if you actually one
would he be more apathetic or energized
no time the people his supporters are
everybody everyone uh well depends we
voted for i think is gonna be incredibly
divisive and polarizing either way it
goes it's going to be of its gonna be
untenable I don't see I I mean Donald
Trump is not one I think the worst case
scenario for unity is Donald Trump
because Donald Trump is not going to
pretend to try yeah unify America no no
doubt about it there's not going to be
any pretending of whatsoever thank you
so much for the call really appreciate
it let's get to that 860 number I think
this is our Connecticut caller or at
least with a connecticut number you're
on what's going on okay glad I'm on yeah
i guess the live stream on you
you isn't always up with the call said
okay okay so like yes that's what you
know I'm in coin I'm calling from Glen
Connecticut I'm a young liberal college
students I really like your show even
though i'm new to it and i was just
wondering because I've barely been
afraid of this I'm wondering what do you
think at least what would you do it now
Trump becomes president any really
destory do they work my plan is to move
to New Zealand well what does I know you
would say yeah I appreciate the call I
don't know I think that hopefully
somebody's gonna prevent Trump from
starting to new people I don't know if
that's gonna happen I mean uh where
you're like we're spiritually crimson
president yep that's a real concern
that's a real real concern I really
appreciate the call we do have another
projection to make here let's go to the
map where Hillary Clinton has indeed one
colorado colorado has now been called
for Hillary Clinton which puts her at
131 electoral votes she is about five
percentage points ahead of Donald Trump
there again this was one that was always
sort of part of the projection for
Hillary Clinton no surprise but tonight
we had a number of uh sort of surprises
in terms of where Hillary Clinton is not
doing particularly well so we are at 167
for Trump and 131 for Hillary Clinton
and just had to have it right Ben I mean
nothing nothing major here Colorado nine
and one of those she she has to have I
mean lisa is anything super surprising
to anyone at this point well yeah
Michigan yeah blows Johnson Florida I
mean I mean honestly you know the margin
it's surprising because Florida Hillary
didn't have a ground game in Florida
particularly in the black community so
surprising that she didn't do that yeah
i'm just wondering what's underlying all
of the wrongful are not wrongful but all
the incorrect predictions yeah um I
don't know it's it's uh it's
trainwreck yeah yeah